chapter one gangster steal a former
hitman's car and kill his puppy a gift
from his late wife Helen is my late wife
and she gave me a dog to help me get
through the days John Wick wants payback
he reconnects with old allies Winston
and Sharon at the Continental Hotel in
Assassin's Safe Haven he takes out half
the Russian mafia and picks up a new
puppy along the way chapter two John is
pulled back into the underworld by
Santino an Italian crime Lord Santino
orders John to kill his sister so he can
take her seat at the all-powerful high
table she kills herself first but John
takes responsibility the high table puts
a bounty on John's head an excommunicado
there's an open contract I'm fighting
for my life John flees to the
Continental Santino is there and John
kills him breaking the Continental code
and becoming a fugitive Tick Tock
chapter 3 John's excommunicado takes
effect his former crime family the ruska
Roma gives him safe passage out of New
York to save the Continental Winston
fakes John's death I don't know if it
fakes Jon's death you know this
character Winston's slippery figure John
is rescued by the outcast Bowery King
together they vow revenge on the high
table now you're ready for John Wick
chapter four
thank you